[Music]
the following is a recording of a man
born in 1807 whose name was Wilford
Woodruff this is a very unique and
special recording not only because he's
one of the few people born in the early
1800s to have been recorded but he was
also a close friend of Mormon founder
Joseph Smith he roam throughout America
in the first half of the 19th century in
the 1830s he was in Ohio where he first
met Joseph Smith then he was a
missionary in Missouri in the later
1830s after that he began preaching in
Arkansas and Tennessee it wasn't until
1850 that he moved to Salt Lake City
where he eventually became the president
of the LDS church in
1889 so a very interesting historical
figure the recording is a little
difficult to understand in places so I
included subtitles to help with that
anyway let's get to it this is Mr
Woodruff speaking on March 19th 1897 at
the age of 90 years
old
all right
there
[Applause]
Illinois
so my
today I bear my testimony
and
foundation
of my testimony
that for and all the called the 12
apostles together have he delivered
through them
the of the Church kingom of God all the
and power that God
has upon
him our head he told us we up our
shoulders
and
all we
would in
the
testimony
his I know to by the power of
God at
that about
hours
and he was covered with a power that I
had never
seen in the place
before I
testimony
[Applause]
all by
the I my
own under his hand and dire and my they
are
princi I not receive my
own under
his but I Bear My Testimony
that and other
receive under the and direction of the
pro d
and also my
wife and other
who I cannot Recall
now Prophet Jord laid down his life all
the word of God and testimony of Jesus
Christ he will be as a in the presence
of God after them
all his testimony to us power of God
visibly benef with the prophet
J this is my
testimony from by
myself into a
ma this
1997 9
by
w
[Music]
oh